-Covering "Do You Really
Want to Hurt Me"
from his new album,
"High Drama,"
give it up for Adam Lambert!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Do you really
want to hurt me? ♪
♪ Do you really want to
make me cry? ♪
♪ Precious kisses,
words that burn me ♪
♪ Lovers never ask you why ♪
♪ In my heart,
the fire's burning ♪
♪ Choose my color, find a star ♪
♪ Precious people always
tell me ♪
♪ That's a step,
a step too far ♪
♪ If it's love you
want from me ♪
♪ Then take it away ♪
♪ Everything's not what
you see ♪
♪ It's over again ♪
♪ Do you really
want to hurt me? ♪
want to make me cry? ♪
♪ Do you really
want to hurt me? ♪
want to make me cry? ♪
♪ You've been talking,
but believe me ♪
♪ If it's true,
you don't know ♪
♪ This boy loves
without a reason ♪
♪ I'm prepared to let you go ♪
♪ If it's love you
want from me ♪
♪ Then take it away ♪
♪ Everything's not what
you see ♪
♪ It's over again ♪
♪ Give me time ♪
♪ To realize my crime ♪
♪ Let me love and steal ♪
♪ I have danced ♪
♪ Inside your eyes ♪
♪ How can I be real? ♪
♪ Mm, mm ♪
-♪ Do you really
want to hurt me? ♪
♪ Do you really want to
make me cry? ♪
♪ Do you really
want to hurt me? ♪
♪ Do you really want to
make me cry? ♪
♪ Do you really
want to hurt me? ♪
♪ Do you really want to
make me cry? ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Do you really
want to hurt me? ♪
♪ Do you really want to
make me cry? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]